[Music]  he hit so hard and I remember there was  a message because you did the sweatshirt  song yeah and then like Tom Hanks  columnist sits and me that was him that  was a good one and then you did a  Hanukkah song and then like Spielberg  called you get a call from from bill  bird I was that was great  he's the top guy it was a great call  like I dare to say I was watching you  and I'm buddy gave him my number and he  left a nice message and he was shooting  Schindler's List and he would be perfect  for that he left a message saying that  he that making the movie was very  depressing and during the shooters very  difficult for and he said somebody  brought that song that had a tape of it  oh and that they watched that and it  would help them laugh and you start  thinking in your mind holy [ __ ] this is  that feels like right nothing happens  right now that my I [ __ ]